what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and today we have some
really really exciting news we have some
news about spider-man we have some news
about wolverine and deadpool in the
future of deadpool in the mcu and some
further news about san diego comic-con
coming up this weekend and disney's d23
event that is going to be coming in a
couple of months now obviously the talk
right now is all about san diego
comic-con i've been covering it a lot
and a lot of people have been asking a
bunch of questions about it and some
people are even at comic con right now
and for those of you who are there and
of course not there right now we have
some really great news concerning
spider-man freshman year the animated
series that is coming from marvel
studios now before anybody bats an eye
at an animated series it is important to
know that they have confirmed that
spider-man freshman year is indeed going
to be canon to the mcu so spider-man
freshman year is a story about tom
holland's peter parker in fact it's
confirmed to be a prequel to spider-man
homecoming so just because it's animated
doesn't mean that it's actually not a
part of the mcu because it is and it's
canon so this is not going to be like
marvel's what if where we were wondering
if any of this eventually ends up being
canon to the mcu doesn't seem like it so
far but this is 100 confirmed to be
canon and is going to be important and
it's going to be fun i mean it's
spider-man and it is now confirmed that
marvel studios and marvel animation is
going to be giving us our first look at
marvel studios as spider-man freshman
year tomorrow at the comic-con marvel
studios animation panel that is going to
be at 11 45 a.m in ballroom 20 for
anybody who is attending and this was
confirmed in a segment of tweets jeff
trammell tweeted this was so fun i could
talk spider-man for my entire life and
probably will so getting to hang out and
talk spidey with this awesome crew of
spidey lovers was a dream in which then
marvel studios executive dana vazquez
eberhard revealed that the animated show
will be giving its first look during
this panel as well she tweeted back
saying that jeff trammell is going to
talk even more spider-man goodness
surprises and first looks at the
animation panel tomorrow so we assumed
that we were going to be getting some
first looks at san diego comic-con and
it looks like the first one that is
confirmed is going to be for spider-man
freshman year now what's interesting is
that there's been a report recently
stating that tom holland is not going to
be returning to voice peter parker which
is going to be weird now of course it's
a voice and voice actors are pretty
amazing plus voices can be manipulated
to sound like other things so they could
pretty much make the voice sound as
close to tom hollands as possible but i
do find it interesting that tom holland
is not returning now big question that
i've been getting a lot lately from a
lot of people is does this mean that tom
holland is done with spider-man in
general and the answer to that is no i
do not believe so i basically believe
that one tom holland is just an
incredibly busy man and two he kind of
needs a break before going back to do
the next spider-man people keep asking
about a spider-man contract with sony
with disney and although nothing
publicly has been stated yet i want you
to keep in mind what kevin feige and amy
pascal said right after spider-man no
way home was released they confirmed the
two of them together both sony and
marvel that they are already working on
the next spider-man film with tom
holland and they specifically said this
according to them so fans would not have
to worry about the future of spider-man
kevin feige said the only reason that
they are telling us that is because they
don't want us to worry about the whole
sony disney deal again like we had to
worry about a couple of years ago where
everybody was pretty much going crazy
but rightfully so spider-man was almost
taken out of the mcu but just cling to
those words even though nothing has come
out in the public i'm sure they've been
talking to tom holland a lot i'm sure
they've talked to zendaya jacob battle
on everybody because also let's not
forget that in the post-credits scene
they set up venom for spider-man 4. so
they already have their plans for the
next movie they already have their
villain and i'm sure tom holland
wouldn't want to miss out on fighting
venom so right now i'm assuming that all
is well now let's get to some really
great deadpool news if you follow hugh
jackman and ryan reynolds on instagram
and on twitter and if you don't you
should you saw the announcement that
logan and deadpool 1 and deadpool 2 are
about to be on disney plus tomorrow july
22nd and they will be uncensored so
completely rated r like you saw them in
the theaters these are our first
projects on disney plus to be rated r
and this is such a great sign for
deadpool 3 and it's also kind of weird
that it's such a big deal now of course
it is disney we typically don't
associate rated r movies with disney
after all that's why they have fox now
they have hulu they have other platforms
where they can produce rated r content
but this is the first time we've seen it
on disney plus and it's a big step
because now we can all feel good about
deadpool 3 remaining rated r if they're
allowing deadpool 1 and deadpool 2 and
logan to be on disney plus there's no
reason that deadpool 3 should not be
rated r this is disney showing us that
they will stick true to these properties
and both hugh jackman and ryan reynolds
took to instagram to announce that these
movies are going to be on disney plus
and they did it pretty much in the exact
way that you would expect each of them
to do it hugh jackman had a pretty
typical post for him he said thank you
disney plus for adding brothers in arms
deadpool movie and logan as the first
rated r movies on the platform while
your choice is questionable we'll take
it and of course he shared a picture of
him hugging ryan reynolds in the
deadpool suit a very nice post a very
warm post a thankful post and then
there's ryan reynolds who is just the
best and of course in his true sarcastic
way he says we're supposed to announce
logan and deadpool will soon be the
first r-rated movies on disney plus but
we all know some disney movies should
already be rated r for irreversible
trauma then he shows and of course these
are made by him they're not real but he
shows some r ratings for some old disney
movies including old yeller and bambi
one says cold-blooded killing of an
innocent deer mom that will cause
lifelong trauma the other one says rated
r for totally ugly cry inducing straight
up murder of old yeller also bear abuse
so in true ryan reynolds fashion he
announced that logan and the deadpool
films will be on disney plus and will be
their first rated r properties and what
i find very interesting about this is
that they are releasing these on disney
plus the day before the marvel studios
hall h panel at san diego comic con
where we are expecting a lot maybe we
shouldn't be expecting a lot but this is
very coincidental now we've talked about
comic con a lot and what to expect so i
won't dive too much into that but keep
in mind that d23 is also only a couple
of months away and based off of the
reports that we've been hearing marvel
studios is actually saving quite a bit
for d23 however this doesn't mean that
there aren't going to be any
announcements made at sdcc because keep
in mind hall age is typically where all
of the big stuff from marvel studios is
revealed is announced and if they don't
announce anything or give us any type of
reveal at all a lot of people are going
to be pretty disappointed now keep your
expectations in check i would not expect
everything to be revealed and i want to
expect super huge things like x-men and
the fantastic four and blade and all of
this other stuff but expect some i would
expect a couple of big reveals and some
release dates and maybe some projects
that haven't been announced yet as well
but just keep in mind that disney's d23
is coming up in a couple of months and
they do have to save some big
announcements for that as well so both
events should be very very exciting and
again it's pretty coincidental that
they're releasing deadpool deadpool 2
and logan on disney plus the day before
the hall h marvel studios panel at comic
con so we'll wait and see what happens
and if you want to stay up to date with
sdcc be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest news for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
you